I think people get so used to sort of
the to think of past pain that an almost
blurs out in their mind.
It's like that sound,
the ringing that eventually your brain
stops processing,
but I think you have a very good rule of
thumb which is the 18 month rule and I
wonder if you could help people
understand that it is not a suffering
that,
that you have to take with you like a
ball and chain for the rest of your
life.
There are ways to release it,
but it does involve circling back and
processing it through.
Yes.
Well,
what?
let's define what processing means.
Okay,
so you know,
let's say let's say that you had a
pretty painful history of being bullied
when you were 13 and you're still
carrying that with you.
You carry it with you and your posture.
You carry it with you in your
assumptions about people.
This is all implicit,
right?
It's not explicit.
You carry it with you in the form of
resentment and the and the questions
about what it might have been and you
carry it with you because you've been
demeaned by it.
But you know,
you're not 13 anymore,
you're 40 and those,
those experiences are not transferable
in any simple,
simple manner to your current reality.
So you go back and you think,
okay,
what happened?
What exactly happened and what what?
What happened means is what were the
causal pathways that put me in that
position of vulnerability and
inferiority and you want to specify them
as carefully as possible because what
the part of you that's hanging onto that
wants to know is have you changed enough
so that that won't happen again,
and if the answer to that is yes,
even through thinking you realize,
well,
I'm not that person anymore,
or you go back to the experience and you
figure out,
oh,
this is what I did and I could stop
doing that.
Then the,
the IC hands of that traumatic
experiment experience will release that.
You can.
You will be released from it because
what your mind wants to know,
your unconscious mind,
let's say is have you resolved this
issue to the degree that it is unlikely
that it will occur again and that's what
it means to you
processed it.
And this.
I think is really important for people
to understand that memory stick until
you gain security memories,
stick to,
uh,
alert you to dangerous that you're
recreating by avoiding the history.
So if you will,
you're going to either end up usually in
the belief victim paradigm,
right?
You're either going to go out there and
say,
well,
I'm going to get them before they get
me,
or you're going to go out there with
your sort of shuffling along,
staring at the sidewalk,
you know,
slumped shoulders,
and you're going to be inviting more
bullies into your life.
And so until you figure out the
causality of how you ended up being
bullied,
you're going to gravitate to either of
those two poles as either a fight or
flight mechanism.
But if you go back and process and
figure out,
okay,
here's the steps that happened that
ended up with me being bullied.
Now I know how to avoid the bullying
situation.
Then that pain will recede.
It's there until you listen.
It speaks until you're safe.
So there's this great scene in this
documentary called Crumb,
which is about the underground
cartoonists Robert Crumb.
It's,
it's,
it's the most brilliant documentary I've
ever seen and it's,
it's highly instructive.
That documentary.
It's about a terribly eatable family,
but it's also about the successful
struggle of one of the brothers in the
family who became a famous underground
cartoonists to free himself from that
and part of the documentary details his
terrible experiences as a 13 to 17 year
old with women.
And he was.
He was one of these people that Robert
Crumb who was not at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy.
He was outside the dominance hierarchy
in the land of absolute contempt.
And he made this card when he was about
13 or 14 with a broken heart on it and
described his realization that he was
such an outsider that he would never be
successful with girls,
you know,
or period.
But particularly with girls.
But then that freed him up and he
started to cartoon more and draw more
and listen to old music.
And he kind of developed his own
pathway.
And then he became a very successful
illustrator.
And then he became very successful with
women.
And so,
but,
but what.
But he,
he drew this picture to illustrate what
he was like when he was 13 and he is
very self critical and he draws himself.
It's kind of hunched over thick glasses,
really skinny,
underdeveloped,
weak chin,
a bad attitude.
I'm poorly presented,
badly dressed like a walking,
a walking testament to resentment and
weakness,
and it wasn't until he realized that,
that,
that he was playing that part and that
that was also fueling his rejection.
Was He really able to to move towards
overcoming it.
And so partly what you want to do is to
go over your past and figure out,
okay,
what stupid things did I do or what in
what manner was I insufficient so that
this negative destiny was more likely to
visit me?
Now you don't assume that everything
that happened to you was your fault or
under your control because everything
isn't your fault and everything isn't
under your control,
but you do want to figure out,
okay,
well if I played some hand in this and
that could be rectified,
well then I should figure out how to
rectify it because then I won't be in
this situation anymore.
And you know,
you talked about the bullied victim who
invites more bullying.
It's like,
well,
if you've conducted yourself in a manner
such that you've attracted the attention
of bullies and you haven't stopped doing
that,
then you're still going to attract the
attention of bullies.
And so your mind is very alert to such
things.
It's always looking for where you're
weak and vulnerable and warning you
about it.
And it's just an alarm bell,
right?
It isn't necessarily a problem solving
mechanism.
And so alarm bells might be going off in
your head all the time and that's very
unpleasant.
But the difficult process of
articulating it and thinking it through
can free you from that.
And so that's what the past authoring
program is for.